et
notre invité politique ce matin c'est
bruno retailleau bonjour bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nos présidents du
groupe l'est républicain ici au sénat
soutien de la candidate valérie pécresse
on est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour
une interview en partenariat avec la
presse régionale représentée par
stéphane bern et de ouest france bonjour
stéphane bonjour bonjour bonjour s'est
fait berner bruno auteuil on va bien sûr
parler du programme et de la campagne de
valérie pécresse mais d'abord
l'actualité ce sont ces images de boue
de chat qui révèle les atrocités
commises par l'armée russe durant cette
guerre avec des massacres de civils un
génocide selon le président ukrainien
volodimir et l'inscrit qui s'exprimera
aujourd'hui devant le conseil de
sécurité de l'onu est ce que au vu de
ces images une solution diplomatique
vous semble encore possible dans cette
guerre ces images et son atroce le
président céline ce qui a parlé de
génocide mais c'est difficile à
documenter un génocide une définition
c'est appartient à une catégorie
juridique
il a parlé aussi de crimes de guerre et
c'est plus simple de le démontrer
quoi qu'il en soit cette abjecte c'est
quoi qu'il en soit on ne peut pas
laisser les choses aller au fil de l'eau
dont je pense qu'il faut bien entendu
documenter ces choses là on voit bien
d'ailleurs dans cette mécanique qui
aboutit à des actes de barbarie à
l'origine il ya toujours une tentative
de déshumanisation cette idée lorsque
monsieur poutine a parlé de d ahnif 10 a
dit fier évidemment traiter quelqu'un de
nazi cc c'est dire contre un nazi on
peut tout faire donc il ya cette
mécanique de la terreur de cette
mécanique de la barbarie qui est
terrible la question vous me posez les
différentes la question que vous me
posez c'est de dire est-ce qu'il faut
pas aller finalement jusqu'à la guerre
totale contre vladimir poutine pour
obtenir la paix non on peut pas
enclencher une guerre mondiale qui
aboutirait sans doute à une guerre
atomique avec des millions de morts il
faudra bien sûr rechercher la paix et il
ya pas d autre voie il n'ya pas d'autre
voie que la négociation vous avez vous
avez entendu peut-être le premier
ministre polonais qui s'en prend à
emmanuel 2010 je cite personne ne doit
négocier avec des criminels iriez vous
négociez avec hitler staline pol pot
qu'est ce qu'elle pensait de sa hanche
et vous que au temps de la guerre froide
le général de gaulle a rencontré brejnev
il a rencontré mao tsé toung au temps de
la guerre froide vous aviez des
dirigeants chinois soviétique qui avait
du sang sur les mains pas avec quelques
dizaines ou centaines de personnes
massacrées mais des millions des
dizaines de millions
bien sûr malheureusement il le fait sans
aucun résultat ce que je veux dire c'est
que il faut négocier sauf que pour
négocier il faut rendre le coût de la
non négociation c'est le coût de la
guerre le plus élevé possible comment
pour moi je la dis mes ressentis en
continuant à alimenter l'armée
ukrainienne et d'aller la lire les
sanctions économiques c'est avec succès
avec des sanctions économiques jeu sera
ce faire les choses que jusqu'où on peut
aller en matière de sanction ou qu'est
ce qu'on pourrait faire de plus
aujourd'hui je vais vous dire les
sanctions économiques moralement il faut
le faire mais en réalité ce n'est pas le
plus efficace je pense que le plus
efficace et on le voit bien depuis des
mois il ya une alimentation notamment
sur des missiles anti-char sur des
missiles sol-air contre les hélicoptères
les avions qui sont obligés de voler
parfois basse altitude et l'armée
ukrainienne a obtenu des résultats tout
simplement parce que l avait des armes
qui étaient des armes modernes
et le premier résultat qui est une
victoire puisque l'armée russe a déserté
les alentours de kehl et c'est à cette
occasion d'ailleurs qu'à bout de ça on a
découvert ce crime ces crimes de guerre
et dans d'autres localités donc bien sûr
mais là il faudra négocier parce qu'il
n'y a pas d'autre façon
d'aller à la presse simplement il faut
dans une première phase accepté le
rapport de force parce que monsieur
poutine désormais on le connaît il ne
s'arrêtera que si on la rate et l'idée
d'aller plus loin encore en se privant
très vite deux d'approvisionnement en
gaz et en pétrole russe ça c'est quelque
chose de réaliser pour la france oui
c'est nous on peut laver pas nos voisins
c'est sa vie et ça tout simplement un
mot un pour tous nos amis si j'ose dire
écologistes l'écologie politique ils ont
ils ont là le désastre de la politique
qu'ils ont poussé en allemagne ils ont
poussé les allemands à sortir du
nucléaire
qu'est ce qu'on obtient on obtient une
plus grande dépendance de l'allemagne
aux gaz russe et l'allemagne est
désormais un des pays d'europe qui émet
le plus de gaz à effet de serre donc
c'est l'échec tyrans sont les
conséquences et ce que je crains est
malheureusement on l'a vu parce que
chaque crise ça a été le cas de la
qu'ovide mais c'est le cas de la guerre
chaque crise révèle nos faiblesses et
bien la faiblesse c'est la dîme fin des
souverainetés pour nous qui ont été
diminués souveraineté énergétique parce
qu'elle macro malheureusement tout dans
son en même temps à pratiquer les
tête-à-queue le zig zag il a
malheureusement
pris des décisions mauvais sur le plan
énergétique il se rattrape en fin de
mandat mais c'est déjà trop tard que de
temps perdu on va parler d'un autre
sujet d'actualité c'est la corse de
nouvelles violences ont éclaté en corse
dimanche lors d'une manifestation en
hommage à yves en colonne l'exécutif le
gouvernement a souhaité reporter la
réunion qui était prévue avec l'exécutif
corse pour parler de l'avenir
institutionnel de l'île de la question
de l'autonomie la raison gouvernement ne
peut pas dialoguer dans ces conditions
zig zag c'est déjà trop tard puisque le
gouvernement des mâles macron a dépêché
son ministre de l'intérieur gérald
darmanin qui a parlé sur place
d'autonomie et une autonomie notamment
d'autonomie à la polynésienne ce qui est
une autonomie qui précède tout juste la
dépendance puisque quand vous avez une
autonomie à la polynésienne vous avez un
gouvernement vous avez des lois de pays
et vous avez un et a restreint c'est à
dire un destin un état qui n'a plus que
des compétences d'attribution et la
collectivité des compétences générales
non la grande erreur c'est d'avoir là
encore céder à la violence il ya une
capitulation moi je l' ai vécu c'est une
méthode de gouvernement je n'ai vécu à
notre dame des landes en réalité le
quinquennat dl macron aura commencé avec
notre dame des landes où là on voit bien
qu'il ya une capitulation vis-à-vis des
ultra-violents et au moment où je vous
parle à notre dame des landes il ya des
agriculteurs qui ont été évincés et vous
avez eu des irréguliers dont l'état
régularisent la situation c'est donc la
prime à la violence c'est la prime à
l'illégalité
et puis vous avez à l'autre bout de son
quinquennat vous avez la corse et même
les nationalistes ont dit que en deux
jours de violences il avait obtenu plus
que les autonomistes avait plus tôt
n'avait pas obtenu en plusieurs années
donc c'est une prime à la violence c'est
aussi la marque je pense de ce qu'un
quidam mais du coup qu'est ce qu'un
frère valérie pécresse elle est élue sur
ce dossier passe mais jamais jamais nous
n'aurions négocier le pistolet sur la
tempe mais maintenant comment vous
faites comment vous ramener le calme
mais est-ce que vous discutez est-ce que
vous discutez avec les édiles sur
l'autonomie ou pas du tout on peut on
peut discuter et on peut parfaitement
prévoir un certain nombre de points mais
il n'est pas question d'emmener la corse
sur une étape qui conduirait à
l'indépendance parce que monsieur
simeone qui se prétend autonomistes et
non pas nationaliste en réalité c'est un
nationaliste quand il dit que c'est un
une première pierre dans un processus
historique une première étape dans un
processus historique
bien sûr et bien sûr pour jusqu'à
l'indépendance pour pour c'est une étape
évidemment quand vous dit je une étape
il a parlé d' étape ou deux premiers pas
dans un processus historique c'est quoi
l'aboutissement d'après vous du
processus historique qu'est ce qu'ils
apprennent autonomie l'autonomie en plus
à la polynésienne je lui dis c'est un
peu technique mais je pense qu'il faut
goûter les spectateurs comprennent bien
le choix de ce mot et je vous rappelle
que monsieur darmana à négocier alors
que sur les grilles de la préfecture il
y avait une banderole état assassin et
bien valérie pécresse jamais n'aurait
voulu négocier le pistolet sous la tente
nous irons exigé le rétablissement de
l'ordre monsieur colonna évidemment
qu'il ya une faute énorme de
l'administration pénitentiaire et
j'espère qu'il ya des sanctions jeu ça
n'excuse rien du tout mais enfin il a
participé à l'assassinât d'un préfet de
la république française
oui à propos du rapport du sénat
christophe castaner estime qu'il s'agit
d'un ne souffre 1,2 de cette démarche
qui parle d'un procès d'intention d'une
opération politique qu'est ce que vous
en pensez un procès d'intention
j'imagine qu'ils devaient dire la même
chose monsieur castaner au moment de la
commission denquête de monsieur benalla
voilà et on a vu et on a vu d'ailleurs
que dans cette affaire la ssn avait eu
raison est ce que vous avez trouvé les
excuses les explications sur le sujet
des mêmes macron clair
ben non justement d'ailleurs la
résonance la résonance à cette affaire
c'est pas tellement les sénateurs se
soignait nasa si un porteur que ce soit
à arnaud bazin qui était le président a
l'air de cette commission denquête qui
ont donné sept ce retentissement c'est
beaucoup plus la macro ni y compris
d'ailleurs les deux ministres dépêché en
hâte essayez de bafouiller dans une
conférence de presse pour trouver d
autojustification non encore on a
quelque chose d'extrêmement symbolique
d'abord c'est ce mélange sulfureux entre
le public et puis le privé puisque on
sait désormais grâce au maquereau l'x
vous savez ces mails qui avait été
piraté pendant la campagne sml qui
montrait qu' il y avait plus d'une 10
deux consultants de mckinsey qui avait
travaillé gratuitement c'est leur droit
d'ailleurs pour la campagne d'e mails
mâcon a commencé d'ailleurs par le
directeur associé de mckinsey france
monsieur karine tadjeddine et puis
ensuite tout à coup il ya une explosion
fabuleuse de ces dépenses-là au
gouvernement donc il ya un mélange des
genres avec un soupçon en tout cas on
peut pas ne pas s'interroger sur un
éventuel renvoi d'ascenseur ça ça n'est
pas normal ce mélange des genres
deuxième élément c'est une gestion
calamiteuse de l'état parce que au
moment même où emmanuel macron est en
train de vouloir supprimer les hauts
commis qui mieux que le monde entier
d'ailleurs nous envie parce qu'on a une
haute fonction publique est très pointu
les préfets les diplomates en même temps
qu'il était en train si aujourd'hui de
déconstruire nos cordes excellence nos
corps admistratif d'excellence de hauts
fonctionnaires ils recourent à ces
cabinets privés et on apprend d'ailleurs
que mackinsey depuis dix ans ne paient
pas d'impôt sur les sociétés gérant
calamiteuse vous êtes c'est un scandale
d'état vous allez bien sûr bien sûr
d'ailleurs que vous savez que il ya une
je veux dire que l'afer a été transférée
parce que on pense qu'il ya eu en pense
on est même certain qu'il y a eu en fait
par jure sous serment la commission
denquête hobby à des formes qui sont
très scrupuleuse et on ne peut pas
mentir vous nous avons fait condamner
vous souvenez yard le car le précédent
monsieur bel âne benalla mais on a fait
condamner un professeur de pneumologie
qui avait fait un faux témoignage
nous pensons que monsieur karim tadjine
a fait un faux témoignage est la raison
pour laquelle le président la commission
enquête a transmis à la justice les
éléments donc non c'est pas seulement un
cas isolé c'est une conception de l'état
on peut pas avoir en plus la fonction
publique la plus pléthorique au monde et
en même temps recourir pour un milliard
d'euros à des cabinets conseils qui en
plus ont fait des prestations qui ont
été annulés à hauteur de centaines de
milliers d'euros est ce que vous
comprenez que le parc national
financière
ne me demandez pas à moi je vécus 2010
est vécue 2010 on a eu un certain nombre
en plus d'explications ensuite des
pressions qui ont été exercées sur la
procureure générale par madame
champrenault bon tout ça a été
documentée depuis voilà donc tout ça
n'était pas dans les professions ne les
explique pas je veux pas me l'expliqué
pas là je suis un élu je suis
respectueux des institutions de la vème
république
mais franchement il ya deux poids deux
mesures les pratiques que vous pointez
elle préexistait en fait ça se faisait
depuis longtemps et les collectivités
locales aussi ont beaucoup recours à des
cabinets bien sûr mais quand par exemple
une région fait appel à un cabinet sur
des points très techniques sur une
expertise qui va concerner par exemple
les questions de mobilité les
collectivités peuvent pas intégrer
toutes les compétences mais là c'est
tout à fait autre chose et où elle
excelle finalement dans
l'excès il est sur le mélange des genres
l'excès il est qu' on a confié à des
cabinets d expertise privée la
responsabilité des décisions même de
politique publique au moment des crises
au long des crises ça engage ailleurs la
souveraineté de la france la
souveraineté c'est d'être capable de
prendre une décision de construire une
décision par soi même sur ses centres
subir sur ses propres ressources et là
la souveraineté c'est aussi autre chose
ces cabinets privés mais d'origine
étrangère ont eu accès temps quand même
à des données qui sont des données de
souveraineté là aussi ça pose un
problème de même que ce qui a posé un
problème dans le mélange des genres
c'est que vous aviez des consultants qui
avaient des adresses mails point gouv
comme s'ils appartenaient à
l'administration française et vous aviez
des notes qu'il rendait qui était aussi
sans piller au logo du ministère ça ça
n'est pas possible ça c'est c'est pour
moi même du faux c'est pour moi une
falsification
c'est pour moi une tromperie bruno
retailleau a parlé du programme de
valérie pécresse vous êtes la saison des
100 jours qu'elle ferait pendant les
cent premiers jours si elle est élue
s'est présenté comme un projet de
rupture est ce que ce n'est pas
contradictoire avec le fait de dire qu
emmanuel macron un copier coller votre
programme dont d'abord il n'a pas copié
collé notre programme il a utilisé la
retraite à 65 ans et dès qu'il a
prononcée il a eu peur de saône audace
et quelques jours après elle a dit que
ça ne devait pas une preuve une priorité
il n'a rien prévu par exemple
l'immigration qui va continuer à galoper
si jamais il était élu rien prévu pour
modifier la justice pour essayer de
sortir du laxisme rien prévu non plus en
matière d'endettement dans que non c'est
très très éloignées d'autres parcourent
la rupture où elle est la rupture c'est
qu'avec eu cette idée des cent jours il
faut mettre fin au malaise démocratique
c'est quoi le malaise démocratique
aujourd'hui ce sont des français qui
pensent que la politique ne peut plus
rien pour eux il voit défiler des
gouvernants est en fait c'est toujours
la même chose tout rien n'est possible
c'est l'impuissance publique et puis il
ya la confiance cette idée que les élus
ne respectent pas leurs engagements et
bien les 100 jours c'est de dire écoutez
on sait que pour y aller fort faut aller
très vite et que si on veut vraiment
bouger les lignes si on veut faire ce
qu'aucun gouvernement n'a jamais fait il
faut méticuleusement soigneusement avoir
tout préparé jour après jour les textes
sont prêts et nous saurons ce que nous
ferons du premier jour jusque non par
jour vous commencez
par vous on commence par une révision
constitutionnelle
on commet des viols il ya deux périodes
il ya la période avant les législatives
parce que pour faire des lois il faut
aussi une assemblée il ya le sénat qui
peut commencer à travailler mais le
sénat peut commencer à travailler
aussitôt après l'investiture et puis
ensuite il ya la période d'après les
élections destatis avant nous faisons
deux choses essentiellement nous lançons
une révision constitutionnelle parce que
c'est si on veut vraiment reprendre le
contrôle de nos frontières de
l'immigration si on veut reprendre le
contrôle notamment de l'an remette de
l'ordre dans nos rues alors il ya des
points de constitution qu'il faut
impérativement changer et surtout elle a
décidé de rendre la parole au peuple
c'est à dire que nous ferons à l'automne
prochain un référendum c'est le peuple
français qui choisira vraiment sa
politique migratoire pour pouvoir donner
la parole au peuple français il faut
modifier dans la constitution l'article
11 ça n'est pas possible aujourd'hui
première chose et puis on n'aura pas
l'assemblée mais on a le pouvoir
réglementaire c'est à dire que les
ministres le premier ministre peuvent
signer des décrets qu'est ce qu'on fera
par exemple je vous en cite quelques uns
on abrogera la circulaire valls 2
novembre 2012 qui régularise les
migrants clandestins deuxième élément on
déconnectera aussi par un décret le prix
de l'électricité du prix du gaz parce
qu'il ya quelque chose que le français
doivent savoir c'est que vous savez que
le gaz en france rentrent pour une
proportion marginale pour la fabrication
d'autres électricité 6% le problème
c'est que les règles européennes font
que on perd prix de l'électricité sur
une indexation prix du gaz ou c'est nous
les français qui sommes les plus
désolante et d'en face à faire votre
première mesure de pouvoir d'achat et ce
sera la première mesure du panda une
autre mesure du pouvoir d'achat c'est de
baisser là aussi des cotisations des
charges sociales voilà on en fera
plusieurs autres et puis ensuite le
deuxième temps dès lors qu'on aura une
assemblée on fera justement des grandes
lois sur la santé déserts médicaux
hôpital sur l'école qu'il faut redresser
parce qu'elle s'est effondré sur
l'immigration j'en parlais quelques
instants sur la sécurité et puis sur le
pouvoir d'achat grâce un projet de loi
de finances rectificatif 10% voilà sur
un certain nombre de les familles les
retraites aussi je crois que tout ce
dont ils sont sourds s'est pas laissée
en jour ou alors les 100 jours sont
immédiats mais ne vous poser la question
autrement est ce que vous pensez que
est-ce que vous pensez que ce que vous
pensez que dans ce prochain ce nouveau
quinquennat quel que soit le président
ou la présidente élue il ya une notion
d'urgence oui qui fait qu'il faudra tout
changer très vite alors là je vous
rejoins je vous savez j'ai consulté ceux
qui à droite ont exercé le pouvoir d'un
président de république premier ministre
directeur de cabinet d'edouard balladur
emmanuelle mignon qui a travaillé avec
nicolas sarkozy et tous évidemment me
disent qu on a quelques mois pour
vraiment réformer et si vous n'êtes pas
prêt le problème c'est que l'exercice du
pouvoir se prépare tout autant et plus
même peut-être que la conquête du
pouvoir ces sacs avec valérie pécresse
et ce qui change tout et c'est ce que je
veux dire parce que parfois on nous dit
mais pourquoi vous aurez le courage de
main de fer ce que vous n'avez pas fait
hier mais non parce que la droite a
changé et parce que on a une nouvelle
méthode qui est de dire justement
instruite par les leçons du passé que il
faut qu'on profite des tout premiers
mois s'ils voulaient s'est passé c'est
tout premiers mois
des blocages qui se met en place deux
questions sur le programme parce qu'il
est vaste on pourra pas tout faire mais
sur la réforme des retraites ça c'est
important pour les français laurent
berger hier il a redit sur notre antenne
qu'il était contre cette réforme et que
pour lui ça ne se justifiait pas
financièrement parlant qui avait pas de
problème de déséquilibre du régime à
moyen et à long terme comment vous allez
faire cette réforme sans la salle voûtée
non mais je respecte évidemment la cfdt
les partenaires sociaux il y en a besoin
mais on peut pas dire ça je l'idée de la
cfdt c'était les 35 heures est-ce que ça
a été une grande idée pour enrichir les
travailleurs pauvres je crois pas un mot
de même qu'ils ont portés eux jadis là
l'idée de la retraite à 60 ans non il ya
le corps nous le dit il a un déficit et
on l'a bien fait d'ailleurs demandé aux
retraités puisque emmanuel macron
s'était engagé à ne pas repousser l'âge
de départ à la retraite eh bien ils ont
été appauvris depuis des années une des
catégories française qui a perdu le plus
en pouvoir d'achat ce sont les retraités
donc on peut pas être le seul pays en
europe à rester à travailler jusqu'à 62
ans un salon passerait sans la cfdt bah
écoutez il ya une concertation la
concertation est fait pour dialoguer
pour échanger moi j'espère que sont les
convaincra mais vous pour convaincre
monsieur bergé ce que je lui dis c'est
que on peut pas être le pays qui
durablement dépensent le plus travailler
le moins et le système sociale le plus
généreux tout se tient c'est par le
travail et c'est le message que nous
portons payer le pouvoir d'achat par
exemple c'est par le travail qu'on
améliore le pouvoir d'achat pourquoi est
ce que il ya vingt ans je le dis aussi à
monsieur berger allemand et français
avaient le même niveau de vie pourquoi
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui la différence et
5000 euros c'est parce que nous il ya 20
ans fait les 35 heures et parce que eux
il ya 20 ans il décide de se retrousser
les manches donc 65 ans c'est pas du
sang et des larmes c'est pour garantir
le pouvoir d'achat des retraités etc
pour faire en sorte que sur nos jeunes
n'est pas une charge trop lourde qui
vont peser sur leurs épaules parce que
c'est eux une fois de plus c'est une
dette sociale qu on va leur donner sur
leurs épaules apparaît de la campagne
elle valérie pécresse a plutôt réussi
son meeting porte de versailles ce
dimanche puisque vous est ce que vous
regrettez que ça trop tard abbas et
j'aurais préféré qu'elle prononce ce
discours
parce qu'elle peut encore gagner oui je
vous le demande vraiment très
franchement c'est plus difficile mais
moi je pense parce que il ya une
caractéristique de cette campagne j'en
ai fait plusieurs
à nulle autre pareille différentes c'est
que les français rentrent tout juste
dans la campagne on voit bien d'ailleurs
les mouvements extrêmement important de
licenciés que ces traitements tard en
fait la décision trèfle s'est rétamé moi
je pense voyez que rien n'est joué et
tout va se décider dans les jours qui
viennent et donc après encore gagné je
pense que elle peut gagner en tout cas
moi j'espère encore qu'elle peut se
qualifier rien est impossible tout va
bouger jusqu'au bout
parce que vous savez la marge d'erreur
moi vous connaissez cette région pays de
la loire pilat loire en ouganda donné
partant il ya moins d'un an et puis on a
mis 12 points par rapport aux
compétiteurs de gauche donc ça veut dire
que les sondeurs se sont trompés de 12
points plus à l'abstention - les
sondeurs parviennent à mesurer justement
les intentions de vote donc et elle fait
je vois bien que elle fait une bonne
campagne 1 d'abord sa campagne elle
était quand même la plus attaquée je
trouve qu'elle a eu un régime de
défaveur y compris d'ailleurs sur le
plan médiatique 2 je pense aussi que
elle s'est révélée comme une combattante
comme courageuse et les français dans
l'imaginaire un peu des campagnes
électorales il aime bien les gens qui
ont souffert voyez ça rend les gens peut
être encore plus plus sympathique elle
n'a pas toujours aidé par pas toujours
été aidé par son propre camp je pense à
nicolas sarkozy oui bien une en parler
les gens jeu lors du meeting non mais
qui n'y pas eu je veux dire je suis pas
en train de dire que tout était parfait
bien réussi et c'est simplement je suis
en train de me laver les français est ce
que vous trouvez que nicolas sarkozy
affaibli pas trace moi je pense que il a
je vais vous dire ma conviction profonde
c'est qu' il n'y a plus on n'est plus
dans ce temps où il ya des hommes
politiques qui avaient un pouvoir de
prescription sur des millions
d'électeurs s'est terminée parce que les
français sont totalement autonome donc
je pense que tout ça c'est ni chaud ni
froid c'est ça ça ne bouge pas une voix
en revanche en revanche moi je pense que
elle peut bouger parce que on voit bien
je l'expliquais pour les cent jours elle
a le meilleur projet vraiment tout le
monde reconnaît qu'elle a meilleur
projet pour redresser la france l est
pas c'est vrai que et préfère être dans
des discours factuel concret n est pas
du tout dans le lyrisme dans le
romantisme et où ça nous mène qu'est ce
que les français préfèrent qu'ils
préfèrent un président de république qui
fait le show en permanence un comédien
un bon comédien mais un comédien ou est
ce qu'ils préfèrent une précision de la
république qui fera vraiment le job un
bon hôtel parce qu'il nous reste très
peu de temps eric zemmour a écrit une
lettre aux électeurs des républicains et
r vous et moi savons valérie pécresse
n'ont pas nos valeurs c'est ce qu'il dit
qu'est ce que vous répondez à saïdia
elle n'a pas su vous parler pendant
cette campagne
ce que je dis c'est que on a des
différences fondamentales avec eux
monsieur zemmour il est tombé très vite
dans la démagogie l'immigration zéro
pour dire d'ailleurs dont même interview
que ça sera du cas par cas c'est de la
démagogie ça ne se fait nulle part
ailleurs si peut-être en corée du nord
est ce que l'on veut que la france est
le destin de corée du nord et puis les
excès regardez la police des prénoms moi
j'ai pas du tout envie que demain l'état
impose que si j'ai des enfants d'avoir
tel ou tel prénom regardez l'islam et la
confusion entre l'islam et les 5000 f
les
réfugiés regardez les réfugiés ukrainien
non je veux dire je suis fier que l'on
départements la vendée accueille
aujourd'hui des femmes est très juste
dans cette campagne faisait pas trompé
de stratégie les l'air en ménageant trop
eric zemmour en négligeant peut-être
marine le pen fait débat dans une
tribune au monde
notre faiblesse a été d'abandonner le
terrain au rassemblement national est ce
qu il a raison mais il a raison mais
vous savez bien enfin je porte une ligne
politique et j'ai toujours considéré que
depuis 30 ans la droite avait vécu sous
une forme d'hégémonie intellectuels
médiatiques
de la gauche les politiques de la gauche
et sur un tient aux deux plateaux
fallait pas parler d'immigration fallait
pas parler de valeurs fallait pas parler
de la fierté ou d'identité mais si
l'identité je viens aussi d'un
département qui puise dans ses racines
dans son identité les ressources pour
aller de la république hors des erreurs
de fond
depuis 30 ans oui depuis 30 ans est en
panne depuis tenteront depuis trente ans
je pense que la droite n'a pas
suffisamment assumé les valeurs de
droite je pense que dans cette campagne
et on l'a bien vu d'ailleurs pendant la
primaire nos candidats pendant la
primaire ont convergé sur une ligne qui
n'était plus l'ancienne ligne mais
qu'était une ligne d'une droite vraiment
assumé sans concession mais sans excès
aussi est-ce qu'il est redoutable dans
les excès marine le pen s'est pas
l'excès c'est à dire ou plutôt c'est
l'excès de
2 comment dirais-je de révolution ou
plutôt de changement parce que sur
chaque point elle a fait un tête-à-queue
je sais plus en elle je ne sais même pas
si elle même le sait et puis un zemmour
il ya un côté très idéologique qui a un
côté esprit de système qui méconnaît en
fait les situations humaines
particulières merci beaucoup raynaud
retailleau merci et vous reviendrez
évidemment nous voir après c'est le
premier tour pas comparer les deux là
sont merci la lutte et bien sûr mais on
vous invite avec plaisir merci d'avoir
été avec nous ses fans la une de ouest
france pouvoir d'achat retraite les
projets des candidats
[Musique]